Hey okay that's starting to be hard okay
let's stop to think what do we know
about this we don't have the first-fruit
always going to work every time so at
least when I'm able to when I'm doing
the roots of unity
the first reason some ways I'm kind of
already doing that but I can't enjoy
that addiction when you go back to these
guys right you can only do this for you
can't do it for two because you can't
have a two sided polygon once again two
three
can you see that the shape traced out by
the roots is an equilateral triangle you
see that and when I have a look at that
to the full one again I thought that
equilateral quadrilateral which in this
context we would call a square you
couldn't rhombus first but then it is a
square because why is it arise that's
some very better that's a very efficient
way to Israel okay
you couldn't tell something to do it
English some of the triangles in here
you could say all 294 but that's a more
direct way to do it so I've got a
triangle a square now here I'm going to
get it I run this a collateral I'm gonna
get a regular pentagon right I can use
that to my advantage
without doing any of the actual
computation I know that the angles at
the center are all adding up to 2 pi or
3 memories from anything so sorry
so therefore when I divide by five
because I need five points around the
circumference 360 divided by five is
very close to 350 divided by which is 70
plus there - okay so 72 I think I can
roughly do something - I think it's
gonna be something like this here's my
first solution there 72 plus 7 2014 for
144
there's 135 right that's like 3/4 in way
so hundred forty-four is gonna be a big
pass that something like that so now
I've got my zip one which of course is
one I've got when said to up here which
is where first reading actually it's not
that hard by the way you can write quite
quickly because I know this is what's
the aim of what's the argument key in
radians remember you're gonna go around
two pi interlocked and you're you're
five times so therefore it's clearly
gonna beat you plan five right because
once you do that five times you does
that make sense so here at five x plus I
sighting I'm not going to bother writing
the rest of them because I think you can
work that out that's two point five this
guy will be 4 PI on five there's my
solution but once I get here
once I add the next 72 degrees I'm
clearly outside the principal argument
yes so I have to go this is Kate was
zero keys cables one so now I try K
equals negative one right now waste glue
together that way but if your cake was a
DS one kita I added one lot of two point
five that will be that extra angle like
this guy here see how at UK pilot three
but now I'm gonna have two K PI of five
right so this is the first one so when I
can we reverse those tables they're on
the opposite angles right once
anti-clockwise and ones clockwise which
is why these guys must necessarily be
conjugates of each other you see what's
going on okay one last one that was
there for
and if you want to be really pretty cool
to take rap suggestion you can see I've
got one two three four by the way that's
one so complex conjugates see that five
and is my well okay now I'm going to
stop for a second okay you can finish
this shape but I'm going to show you
because there's plenty of time I want to
show you what this looks like and then
you're gonna help me work out some
patties okay so that's the first ones in
the body whose one I wonder what you
would guess said the five equals
negative one hey say okay is what I
prepared they know what's going on right
you can see but first even though it's
def three the first solution I put in
was negative one y one but also give to
the factorization they did it but even
more like simply than that it doesn't
take much like it's equal trial and
error I will tell you if you haven't
want Palamon right the even bunch of
them the [ __ ] will cancel which will
leave you exactly one taken which is the
one that one gets you didn't use one
okay
then when you do that again you process
your angles there's still five solutions
and they still evenly spaced around
around the circumference but instead of
starting over here I'm starting over
here right so I've got that huh
I've got a Pentagon facing the other way
okay all right now let's have a look at
it seeks but now I want you to look at
this particular on the right hand side
in case - bit unusual well I'll show you
I hope you can see why in a second this
is familiar isn't it
don't you have an Argand diagram in your
mix that looks almost like them to clean
like this this was exactly right we
looked at Z to the 6 equals negative 64
now if you look carefully at my diagram
that suits yours the diagrams are
identical with one difference what's the
difference there's only one difference
the modulus thank you very much right
this here is in 64 means on what a
radius of sorry a circle of radius 2 all
right
so therefore when I do this it's just a
circle which is half the size or
quantity very well anyway okay so it's
smaller but you see important thing and
I've actually written this over here
which we can write as well right the
reason why I can consider only the
complex roots of unity right and the
negative
maybe of impunity and not worry about
like what about 64 or whatever I didn't
know but you liked it's real okay do you
see that all solutions to polynomials if
they're taught that's not real roots I
meant to say group coefficients sorry
all they are just like yours into the 60
was negative 64 it's just a scalar
version of these complex numbers Z to
the sixth equals maybe 64 it's just ask
an old version whose into the six
because negative one it's just twice
little twice and one to us that's the
only difference
okay the are getting to the same the
moduli different and just as an easy
example right you think about these
square roots of one and then you think
about the square roots of saying 25
right also minus one they're in the same
spots best as possible is five there's
still same arguments 0 and PI but they
just further away the militia list is
big up that's the only difference
ok all solutions are pollinated with
real coefficients
I just scaled versions of these guys ok
and doesn't matter if you have like two
plus the square root of three or you
know 1/2 plus whatever like all of those
are just bigger and smaller versions
because they
all the relaxes okay question now okay
I'm gonna make my final occupant or fall
of sit in the center okay here we go
okay now you've got a regular hexagon
there right excuse me can you see why if
I have real coefficients right last one
for 64 or 2 plus root 3
they're all just here on the real axis
right what that means is your first root
is always either here or here but it's
always gonna be the first root will
always be a real number itself so then
what you do K equals 1 and then K equals
negative 1 right you're going the same
angle up in the same angle down so you
get conjugates does that make sense and
then you go to lots of that angle eight
o'clock wise to lots of that angle 80
clockwise so of course you're going to
get conjugates did you see that
so here we go I'm ready to get the
complex conjugate the Arab states all
polynomials that something to do
everything right all polynomials that
have only real coefficients
right have complex roots that are always
in conjugate pairs they have complex
roots that are always in kanji Japan's
so when you are dealing with things like
this zette cubed equals 1 or Z to the
300 equals 1 or anything like that
or in fact 10 or 10 plus or 3 or
anything where these are all real
numbers ok if you find a solution set 1
right I can bet your bottom dollar that
Z 1 the conjugate will also be a
solution because you're always
reflecting across the axis ok now this
was an informal geometric argument and
we were using these regular polygons to
help us ok there is a rather more
sophisticated algebraic argument but
honestly this is all you need this is
all you need in order to recognize this
fact because you're going to be solving
quite a few of these ok